hallo liebe zuschauer es ist ende
oktober in berlin
bald steht der winter bevor und so haben
auch einige von euch uns gefragt wie ist
das eigentlich im winter in deutschland
zum beispiel schreibt morgen hallo kari
ich wohne seit sechs monaten in berlin
und ich habe angst vor meinem ersten
europäischen winter was kann man machen
um den winter in berlin zu überleben
ja das fragen wir jetzt einfach mal die
menschen auf der straße und vielleicht
erhaltet ihr dann mal ein paar wertvolle
tipps was man im winter in deutschland
machen kann
kommst du selber aus berlin ja klar was
war dein härtester winter bisher
ich muss sagen die werden von jahr zu
jahr immer hat er ganz egal wie kalt es
ist
weil irgendwie vertraglich den winter
nicht mehr deshalb muss ich auch
unbedingt diesen winter weg dahin
na hoffentlich nach thailand oder nach
indien ach das hat er immer dann am
besten urlaub an
oder man das haben wir heute auch schon
gehört aber wenn man jetzt wirklich in
berlin bleiben muss man hier bleibt
therme ja also thermen sind immer gut
letzte mal gut aus viel spazieren gehen
zumal die sonne scheint wir genießen die
natur viel guten tee ich laufe sehr viel
und also die normal laufen jetzt nicht
joggen aber einfach laufen
da wird man ja war
dann habe ich warme sachen an auf jeden
fall kleidung kleidung auf jeden fall
lange unterhosen alles handschuhe alles
was geht nicht dass man schall und so
weiter alles was da gibt's anziehen
ja und jetzt noch ein tipp von uns ein
paar tipps die wir euch herausgesucht
haben
tipp nummer 1 ist natürlich warme
kleidung ein deutsches sprichwort sagt
es gibt kein schlechtes wetter es gibt
nur falsche kleidung
und so sollte man aufpassen dass man
sich was warmes holt auch die kleinsten
werden hier schon fein angezogen für den
winter und der tipp nummer eins ist
gefütterte schuhe futter ist in
deutschland nicht nur für essen sondern
auch dafür wenn man etwas will oder
wolle noch unter der kleidung schicht
darunter hat und so ist dass sie zum
beispiel ein gefütterter schneeanzug
schulkinder mit einem warmen tier in
einem guten buch in eine kundin einen
decke also man muss jetzt nutzen
irgendwie weiter leben auch wenn es kalt
ist und deswegen gute ersten gute socken
und dann ab durch die kälte ja gut
haushalten mit körper energie also halt
irgendwie sich gut ernähren
zu hause hat sich schön einrichten
tipp 2 um den winter zu überleben von
mir persönlich ist kopf hände und füße
warm halten weil das sind die
empfindlichsten partie in des körpers
und wenn man die hände warm hat den kopf
warum hat und die füße richtig warm hat
dann ist der rest eigentlich egal
klare gedanken schön tanzen gehen gerade
in berlin gibt so viele möglichkeiten
auch in kunstausstellungen zu gehen
es gibt so viele so viele sauna so viel
spar angebote unterschiedlichster art
kommt er aus berlin hamburg
aber wo jetzt hier haben wir euch keller
oder in berlin
berlin die sozia auch die auf sozial was
heißt das denn soziale kälte
dann werde ich auch sagen wenig aufwand
aber in hamburg kasse ist die luft ein
bisschen klares ganz schön am hafen und
so blauer himmel das war nicht kälter
wenn die der wind kommt also hier ist
echt kälter skiunterwäsche trocken da
ist alles super als einem warmen
ansonsten reichelt sagen lieber erstens
nicht so schlimm in berlin wenn es
winter ist es geht eigentlich letzten
winter nicht so geil also es war nass
und eklig oder schnee hat sich lange da
dies so matschig was soll der härteste
winter den du bisher erlebt hat in
berlin vor 23 jahren war ich jedes 20
mit 22 20 war dass man da draußen noch
machen gar nichts so schnell herkam
lorenz ichenhausen und taxis u bahn
fahren derzeit auch super zum feiern
gehen macht man ist man ja warm bleibt
gar nicht so viel benzin wirklich
richtig eiskalt der so minus zehn grad
was macht man da noch glühwein trinken
ja der nächste tipp für euch ist
glühwein trinken zumindest ist dass das
was die leute und sagen alle leute
trinken glühwein und wenn ihr aus einem
land kommt wo sowas nicht gibt fragt ihr
euch natürlich was ist das glühwein ist
im prinzip so etwas wie ein roter wein
der heiß gemacht wird wenn man schon
keinen wein mag dann schmeckt ein grüner
in erst recht nicht irgendwie trinkt man
es meistens trotzdem ich persönlich mag
es nicht so gerne aber in den letzten
jahren gab es immer mehr variationen es
gibt mittlerweile apfelpunsch
verschiedene arten himbeer punsch es
gibt cacau warmen kakao das ganze jetzt
immer mit und ohne alkohol also für
jeden ist etwas dabei um sich draußen
aufzuwärmen
also da würde es jemanden nicht
empfehlen im winter in berlin zu
verbringen
die berliner sind auch ganz unerträglich
im winter noch schlimmer als sonst noch
stimmt naja ich finde jedem sommer finde
ich die super aber im winter bezahlt
alles ist grau alles ist kalt wenn es
dann nicht mal schnee liegt da und alle
sind zugeknöpft ja ich mag den winter
einfach nicht sein dass man wenn meine
abscheu berlinern gegenüber dann
daherkommt was hab ich denn noch
und auf rügen nein
nein zu machen dass ich nur ein bisschen
nur ein zimmer das wissen und das so zu
machen und warum energiefragen
doch ein bisschen billiger dann ist es
halt auch von der luft schöner sonst ist
halt so trocken
das mag ich nicht wer noch ein weiterer
tipp für euch ist es gemütlichkeit
gefühle zu entwickeln im deutschen gibt
es so ein wort das heißt gemütlich und
das hat etwas mit einem gefühl zu tun
dass das gefühl kann man haben wenn man
rausgeht weil man schon daran denkt wenn
man wieder reinkommt aber vor allem geht
es um die eigene wohnung um die eigene
atmosphäre ist es irgendwie gemütlich
wenn man rausgeht und dann in was an ein
warmes kaffee kommt oder in die warme
wohnung wir haben ja auch mal dazu eine
ganze episode gemacht die ihr jetzt noch
mal seht kriegt einfach mal auf den link
dann seht ihr was gemütlich ist im
deutschen wie kalt kann es überhaupt
wären in deutschland vor worauf müssen
sich die leute gefasst machen kommt auf
anderen bayern hast du locker - 20 wir
haben wir 28
die stadt war hart was sie was macht
sich dann die macht sich das bemerkbar
auf den straßen er ist kalt
er wollte wissen wie kalte wird es
überhaupt im winter in deutschland in
berlin
ich habe nachher guckt der kälteste
winter war glaube ich - 26 grad aber man
muss dazu sagen da sind ja immer nur ein
paar tage und letzten winter zum
beispiel war es die meiste zeit also um
und das ist für uns eigentlich gar nicht
so kalt man kann vieles man kann vieles
eigentlich genauso machen wie im herbst
oder im frühling oder so man muss das
hat einfach machen und gucken dass man
in die gänge kommt köln
es sei auch möglich macht ihr eigentlich
im winter war es sehr warm oder sage ich
ab so dass man immer im sommer grillt
und eigentlich wäre es auch besser im
winter also liebe leute das war's auch
schon für diese woche wir hoffen ihr
konntet ein paar tipps mitnehmen wie ihr
den winter in deutschland über stehen
könnt aber jetzt möchten wir gerne auch
von euch partitionen was denkt ihr wie
kann man im winter was kann im winter am
besten machen
es gibt ja auch einige von euch die
kommen aus ländern wo es noch kälter ist
in deutschland zum schluss nochmals
schönen dank an alle von euch die uns
bei katrin unterstützen
wir machen jetzt seit diesem monat jeden
tag ein video für euch ganz verschiedene
formate wir hoffen das gefällt euch und
das ist alles dadurch möglich weil ihr
uns jeden tag unterstützt danke dafür
und wir sagen tschüss und bis zur
nächsten woche